no understand how I love my father let's
talk about my father I like this I like
this where whoever pushing about my
father you sometime you don't respect
your parents you have to remember
everything when you grow up how they
support you how they give you life you
know this is very important be your
parents close and that's it
I wanna say thank you so much God I
wanna say thank you for my father
assalamualaikum greetings a piece I
wanted to go ahead and reflect on the
recent passing of hobbies father we want
to send our drawers our salams to him
and his family and making it God
Almighty the creator Allah I mean he
eased their pain eased their trial and
reunite grant their father Jenna and
insha'Allah reunite him with his father
in Jenna so there's three points that I
just wanted to cover real quick what
what actually happens we often hear this
statement well when a person dies that
he went to a better place
he died in peace there's some truth to
the statement but let's analyze this
quickly in context yes for a believer a
person who lived their purpose who
prepared for the match meaning that if a
person neglected their duty and I'll
specifically make an example for some of
these USC fighters they'll probably
watch this if you didn't prepare for
your match if you didn't train hard if
you didn't follow the regimen of your
coaches your nutritionist and now you
step in that ring
most likely you're not going to have a
good match you're not going to have a
good day but we have a bigger match this
test that we are living in right now and
if a person fulfilled their ultimate
purpose not a subjective purpose when
someone's asked this question many
people they fall into a trance they fall
into a dumbfound look when you're asking
a person what is the purpose of life why
have you been created
you know people give subjective answers
whoa I've been created to be as UFC
fighter well I've been created to
love and live and I've been created for
this and that and everything under the
Sun but nobody is truly investigated
what is the ultimate purpose in life but
when a person seeks to know they shall
find out if there's sincere humble heart
and ask the creator of the heavens and
earth God Almighty Allah will guide them
so now hey if a person truly lived
according to God's will not their
desires then they will as we know the
angels will come and they'll give them
glad tidings of the meeting with their
Lord that their Lord is pleased with
them they shouldn't grieve or be sad and
they will be in a good place you know
there's just this is a there's so many
details of what happens after death in
Islam it's amazing like nothing else out
there having a complete description from
A to Z of the what happens after death
so we have one description of a person
in their grave they'll be shown the
Hellfire for example and a terrifying
sight but then though they're going to
be told that this is what you would have
been in you would have been in the felt
Hellfire if you would have followed your
desire as if you were to worship other
than God Almighty the creator and you
would have lived the life of negligence
and not fulfilling your true purpose but
then they'll be shown paradise and
they'll be told this is what is waiting
for you so that person has a good ending
that person because they live the
ultimate person to the other thing is
that for us now living is this just when
we hear about these things it's a time
of reflection it's a time to think I was
talking to a person the other day and
one of their family relatives caught
cancer and they were just like in a
state of shock numbness but these
feelings they're there for a reason to
have us reflect to have us to think
because pretty soon that feeling will
leave but either you capitalize on that
feeling right now and you think okay
that person was living that person is
gone I'm living I'll be gone everything
seems to be in the past tense I was here
I was there I was the UFC champion I was
the greatest I was this I was that but
then you know I was here I was there
but then the party's over the lights
come on it's finished what do you have
left the hangover I mean it's a time
when these things happen when we hear of
someone passing these are one of the
ultimate signs that there is a creator
that there is accountability and it
doesn't make sense that we will go
through this life and at the end we just
die and turn to dust that doesn't make
any sense
so number two the point is to really
reflect and many of us feel that pain
it's real someone passes and in this
case Habib's father and now how can I
take from that what is the wisdom that I
can that I can gain is that he beat us
to it and I'm headed there so what am I
going to do about it am I going to
prepare like I prepare for my UFC match
am I going to prepare for that moment of
death that can come today tomorrow next
week
it can come and there is no like you
can't just live like how you want to
live ignore all the signs this is a sign
is coming to you and then at the end
think that I'm going to win the match
this is the match of life this is the
test of life are we prepared for what
comes next so that's point number two
and point number three and I'll conclude
is that there's a beautiful ayah in the
verbatim word of God Almighty the Quran
and it really emphasizes this point of
death in the original Arabic which the
Quran was revealed in tamper free tamper
proof we have it in its original if
you've read every other book you owe to
yourself to read it Rita is a potential
but we know as Muslims Muslims one who
simply submits his or her will to the
creator of heavens and earth God
Almighty Allah the same way Jesus Moses
Abraham and all the messengers they
submitted to one God Muhammad peace and
blessing be found just being the last in
a line of those messengers who called
people to worship one God to be morally
upright complete blueprint for life
that's all for another discussion but
now in this Quran that's a living
miracle we have God Almighty Allah
speaking to us and he says calluna
syndicate Olmo to anima - whoa phone Oh
Judah Komiyama Nakayama
comenzó eonni nerdy what hello Janet
offical d'affaires
well hiya - Dona Allah metal look at
this
Carol Mary Allah is saying very powerful
pay attention take heed every soul will
taste death and only on the day of
judgement will you be paid back your
full recompense only that person who is
removed he who is removed far from the
Hellfire and admitted to the Jenna to
the Paradise has achieved the objective
of this life because the life of this
world is merely the goods and chattels
of the section is that that's deep so
what is true success it is being removed
far from the hell fire because the
Hellfire is real it is real and we we
want to be removed far from the Hellfire
and how you're gonna do that by obeying
your Creator by knowing your Creator and
when you know your Creator you will love
your Creator and when you love your
Creator you will obey your Creator and
when you do that that's how you're
prepared for death that moment that it
comes like it came to Hobie's father and
it's gonna come to Habib it's gonna come
to me it's gonna come to my father to
all of us so when we implement this we
prepared a law is telling us God
Almighty's telling us that every soul
will taste death so now that should have
us thinking be on guard not be racing
for all of the materialism of this life
following a person's lusts passions and
desires debauchery and all that other
stuff but now you live how your Creator
wants you to live you slip and fall but
you get right back up and you hang in
there and then a person inshallah God
willing we'll be by God Almighty's grace
mercy and love be removed far from the
Hellfire and that's the objective that's
the purpose that's a part of worshiping
your Creator alone without any
associates or partners and that's the
objective and purpose of life as God
Almighty Allah is saying in the Quran
like no other book no two philosophers
can get it right arguing over this day
and the other calling people to the
purpose of life and God Almighty again
reminds us in the Quran well now hold up
the agenda will in Salaria Badoon I have
not got almighty saying I have not
created the jinn and the mankind except
to worship Him and worship Him alone and
worship is doing everything that God
Almighty loves
and staying away from everything that he
told you to stay away from its worship
so with these points I want to conclude
and again we send our duas our salams
and das to habib and his family and may
God Almighty Allah grant his father
forgive his father and grant him Jenna
and reunite him hobby with his father
and Jenna and us also forgive us our
shortcomings and give us all a good end
and grant us Jenna because that's what
our GPS should be set to working in this
life so we can pass this test of life
and so we can get because this life is
transitory it's short it's going to end
at any time and we don't want to be
losers in this life because this life
we're gonna lose and then we invested
all of our efforts in this life we lost
it and then we didn't invest anything
for the next life and then we lost that
too no now we want to set a legacy of
doing good deeds of living our true
purpose so we can plant seeds of
goodness so we can be winners in this
life leave a good legacy behind that's
going to be transferable credits to the
next life and that's the real life
because that is forever forever ever yes
forever ever thank you
peace be with you assalamualaikum
[Music]
[Music]